[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat politique
l'exécutif face à la gestion de la crise
sanitaire mercredi un rapport d'étape de
la mission d'information parlementaire
de l'assemblée nationale a révélé des
faiblesses stocks de masques insuffisant
situation tendue à l'hôpital avant la
crise ou encore agences régionales de
santé trop centralisée l'at on verra un
procès politique ou pas c'est la
question de notre débat ce soir avec
aurélie gros conseiller régional
d'ile-de-france et présidente de la
france vraiment bon soir aurélie gros en
soit également pour débattre ce soir
nous sommes avec jean paul huchon
président honoraire du conseil régional
d'ile-de-france bonsoir à tous les deux
merci avec nous sur rt france alors
l'état doit-il rendre des comptes dans
sa gestion de la crise sanitaire faut-il
désigner des responsabilités en tout cas
ce n'est pas le but de cette première
mission d'information dont on a eu les
résultats mercredi
écoutez ce rapport d'étape il est au
fond à l'image de ce qu'a été le travail
parlementaire et la vie parlementaire
pendant la période du confinement
travaille essentiellement contemplatif
si si le but d'un travail contemplatif
c'est de ne pas dire qu'il ya des
responsables au bout de la chaîne
eh bien c'était pas le but de cette
mission d'information donc ce n'était
pas le but de cette mission
d'information jean paul huchon ce le but
n'est pas de désigner des responsables
qu'en pensez vous d'abord je sais qu'il
y a deux missions parlementaires qui
sont au travail
l'une au sénat une assemblée p elles ont
donné leur sang culture librement et par
ailleurs j'ai appris mais je ne sais pas
si c'est confirmé que l'elysée
souhaitait engager une nouvelle
commission qu'il désignerait pour faire
le point sur ce qui s'est passé c'est
franchement un peu choquant par rapport
à la démocratie française et au poids du
parlement
ce qu'il faut regarder d'une part c'est
est ce que au départ on avait tous les
éléments pour prendre des décisions
je crains que non parce que on a
sous-estimé la virulence du virus
sa capacité de diffusion et le fait qu'
il fallait sans doute remonter plus en
avant plus en plus en amont pour savoir
quand ces choses avaient commencé ça
c'est le diagnostic il n'a pas me
semble-t-il été portés exactement comme
il faudrait ensuite il ya la deuxième
partie c'est à dire cette saga
invraisemblable sur le manque de moyens
les masques les tests et caetera et ofi
et ça c'est important
l'état de notre système de santé qui
s'est dégradée où puise les années n'est
pas seulement du fait du gouvernement
d'aujourd'hui on a mis les l'hôpital en
particulier en situation d'économies
forcées et en situation au fond d'être
gérée comme une entreprise les mal gérée
comme une entreprise et enfin le
troisième fois c'est le le confinement
fallait-il ne fallait-il pas je pense
que c'est clair que les résultats
montrent qu'il fallait le faire alors on
en était là jean paul huchon sur la
pertinence sont pas du confinement
on en est là justement cette mission
d'information était pour savoir si la
crise a été bien gérée avec les moyens
dont dispose est évidemment le l'état
faisait mieux de dire qu' on ne peut pas
dire que c était bien gérée en termes de
diagnostic bien gérée qu'en terme de
démarrage du confinement quand il
fallait et ensuite le déconfinement a
été mieux réussi à lévis damman alors il
ya est ce que vous dites la mission
d'information dont on connaît
les résultats il ya eu des faiblesses
avérées c'est ce qu'a dit le président
de l'assemblée nationale cette semaine
il ya aussi une commission denquête de
l'assemblée nationale qui va se tenir
vous l'avais dit à partir du mois de
juin idem pour le sénat aurélie gros la
question est de savoir d'ailleurs c'est
ce que dit boris vélo est ce que il faut
désigner des responsables mais ce qu'il
faut désigner des responsabilités au
lieu d'être contemplatif c'est le mot
qu'il a qu'il a utilisée oui merci
magali mais je pense qu'avant de rentrer
tant dans le détail des responsabilités
des uns et des autres je crois qu'il
faut quand même énoncé le principe
essentiel un principe essentiel c'est
que notre démocratie
c'est un système qui suppose un
engagement mais un engagement qui est
collective et qui suppose aussi que les
citoyens soient éclairés c'est pourquoi
nos élus agissent d'abord et avant tout
au nom du peuple et donc doivent
connaître la une c'est avant tout une
sanction politique à l'égard des
éventuellement nombril par être tenu
pour responsable
c'est pour moi c'est la sanction
politique la première sanction qui doit
qui doit arriver dans les rues aux yeux
on va essayer dans les urnes pour
sanctionne les élus et à cet égard à mon
sens le gouvernement est là la reine
dans la public en marche
on fait quand même preuve d'un certain
courage en matière d'élection quand ils
ont organisé leur élection fin juin car
à l'évidence ils vont très clairement
payé très cher l'addition électorale ils
vont la payer très cher l'autre principe
que j'aimerais rappeler c'est que nous
devons nous garder de toute démagogie et
de ce consumérisme ambiant qui fait que
maintenant les services publics
l'action publique tout cela est vécu
comme un contrat presque je dirais que
commercial avec une judiciarisation à
outrance contre toutes les décisions
d'un gouvernement d'une collectivité
moi personnellement je suis totalement
formellement opposé à cette dérive à
l'américaine
s'il ya une faute qui est commise et
c'est déjà arrivé dans la gestion
publique et que sa relève
pénal alors oui on peut être jugé dans
la sphère par exemple si on prend un
exemple qui a été comparé d'ailleurs par
le par le docteur le professeur out dans
le faire du sang contaminé ou dans les
permis de construire de la faute sur mer
il y a eu une mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui les huit en danger des
habitants et la cde tribunal qui en a
jugé donc on verra bien ce qui va ce qui
adviendra de toutes les plaintes
déposées parce qu'il ya soixante trois
personnes je crois qu'ils ont déposé
plainte mais si elle est pourquoi et
quel est son fils sur le plan judiciaire
autant 63 voilà aujourd'hui on n'en sait
rien mais bon voilà on le verra mais
quand on parle anticipation comme l'a
dit jean paul ii stocks stratégiques
organisation des soins ou fermeture des
frontières
on est là sur un terrain qui est un
terrain totalement politique sur des
grands choix du gouvernement
et c'est pas un juge d'en décider si ça
a été un bon choix ou un mauvais joie un
juge
à mon sens c'est pas à mon sens
d'ailleurs un juge est une autorité il
peut prononcer des sanctions
mais ce n'est pas un pouvoir il n'est
pas aisé à c'est la grande différence
fondamentale que l'on a en france avec
les etats-unis et je pense que vous
connaissez bien la formule de la
république des juges
et bien pour faire simple moi je suis
totalement contre
alors vous êtes fond de vous parliez du
sang contaminé ou des vies ont été en
jeu c'est le cas aussi pour le covin 19
des vies ont été en jeu il y a eu
néanmoins des mensonges écouter on en
parle après veut ensuite assurer à nos
concitoyens que notre système de santé
est prêt nous ne sommes pas en réaction
puisque nous sommes depuis des mois dans
l'anticipation depuis des semaines dans
l'anticipation n'y a pas de risque de
pénurie d'abord pour les masques dits
chirurgicaux les bleus un peu pressée
en fait on a des stocks d'état qui ont
été réalisés dans des mandatures
précédentes donc ils sont renouvelés on
les a c'est l'heure de la santé ce sont
les autorités américaines ce sont les
articles publiés
saman et c'est surtout la société
française d'hygiène hospitalière qui
confirme que les masses n'ont aucun
intérêt pour le grand public alors voilà
trois annonces qui se sont avérées
inexactes
le plan blanc on est prêts on a vu ce
que ça a donné après les stocks de
masques qui sont gérés en direct c'est
ce que dit si bête ndiaye la porte
parole du gouvernement
sans rentrer dans les détails évidemment
jean paul huchon mais il ya clairement
eu des mensonges de rentrer dans cette
affaire oui on n'a pas dit le totalement
la vérité aux français et ce que le
gouvernement avait les moyens d'accéder
à cette vérité d'autres sujets parce que
ça met en cause le rapport entre comme
le tiche et au lit un instant entre le
politique et le technicien et et les
administrations
je ne suis pas sûr que la toute
information a été donnée et c'est grave
parce que d'une part on sait très bien
que le système de santé était dans un
état d'épuisement
avant même l'épidémie et ça c'est
quelque chose qui va beaucoup plus loin
que toutes les critiques qu'on pourra
faire dans le détail mais le fait que
par exemple n'est menti carrément sur
les masses parce qu'il y en avait pas et
qu'on ait pris des gens honnêtement pour
des imbéciles ou pour des enfants
c'est quelque chose qui restera comme
une faute à l'intérieur de cette période
également sur le plan blanc il y avait
on dit on est prêt or on a vu finalement
que ça n'était pas le cas manifestement
on n'était pas prêt et il y avait une
grave pénurie à la fois d'infirmières de
soignants de masques s'attira à
l'hôpital c'est miraculeux que l'hôpital
est tenu grâce au dévouement incroyable
de ses personnels
mais très franchement on aurait
aujourd'hui deuxième crif qui
surviendrait est ce que aujourd'hui
enfin on serait prêts préparer s comme
répond alors c'est la grande question
évidemment c'est ce que dit aussi cette
mission d'information
elle recommande d'être prêt et de
reconstituer des stocks pour la
l'éventuelle prochaine épidémie aurait
les gros vous croyez que la prochaine
fois c'est tenter client en est une on
sera prêt dans cette affaire du coc vie
de 19 qui rappelons le est quand même
une pandémie mondiale la plus grave
depuis un certain nombre d'années alors
peut-être pas d'ailleurs dans nombre de
morts ou part activement à d'autres
épidémies mais au moins dans la rapidité
de contagion je pense que les pouvoirs
publics dans le monde entier ont été mis
à l'épreuve et chacun a réagi
effectivement avec ses qualités et bien
entendu ses défauts en france et là je
rejoins pour le coup les premières
conclusions de la mission d'enquêté de
l'assemblée nationale
on a clairement manqué d'anticipation
probablement parce que nous n'avions
nous avions tendance en france à nous
croire au dessus et est sûrement un peu
inatteignable et il n'y a pas que le
gouvernement qui a pu penser ça ou que
les politiques qui ont pensé ça il ya
longue certains professeurs éminents de
la médecine qui l'on pense et je pense
qu'on a entendu beaucoup de déclarations
qui pouvait nous laisser à penser que
jamais ça n'arrivera en france
et oui aujourd'hui clairement notre
machine d'état a été clairement très
lente à se mettre en marche quand dans
certains pays on le sait le confinement
a été décidée en 24 heures alors que
l'on a pris beaucoup plus de temps en
france mais par contre on a eu une
réactivité du système de santé
formidable et d'ailleurs j'aimerais
encore une fois saluer les
professionnels de santé en france parce
que ils ont été cédés héros clairement
ce qui a probablement sauvé plusieurs
d'un grand nombre de vies et on parle
d'ailleurs de l'ordre de 60 et les
soigner ni gros voilà est-ce que le lego
et qui n'a rien à envier aux 46 fin avec
un confinement tout de même très strict
comme ça j'ai un état très directif peut
le faire et une sortie du confinement
très cadré comme l'a rappelé mon
collègue et j'espère du coup peut-être
pas de deuxième vague
al'inverse d'autres pays comme israël on
sait qu'il ya un début de
mba éventuel en israël ou de l'allemagne
où on entend le certaines inquiétudes du
gouvernement allemand donc défaut
d'anticipation
oui soyons et profession essentielle
sous payés parce que ça c'est un sujet
oui agences régionales de santé beaucoup
trop centralisée trois fois oui et j'ai
moi même eu l'occasion de le dire à
plusieurs reprises et de demander à ce
sujet une nouvelle vague de
décentralisation pour en finir
justement avec cette organisation
verticale beaucoup trop éloigné du
terrain parce que c'est ce qui nous
causent du tort aujourd'hui mais en
aucun cas je crois que c'est
responsabilité relève du pénal
la crise cette crispation donnera lieu à
une sanction clairement démocratique
comme jeudi en début d'émission nous
verrons bien laquelle et de quelle
ampleur
par contre lorsqu'on sait le rapporteur
de la commission parlementaire et eric
ciotti le responsable politique qui
voulaient arrêter le virus à la
frontière italienne
on se doute que malheureusement la
polémique et le populisme seront
clairement au rendez vous alors on va
écouter
justement à ce propos une interview de
/ / / de boris vallée au pardon voilà je
cherchais son nom député ps des landes
il parle d' obstruction à la mission
d'information la mission d' enquête qui
est présidée par eric ciotti justement
et il demande à ce que le président de
l'assemblée nationale cette fois ne
fasse pas obstruction écoutez le
s'agissant des gens que nous
souhaiterions les uns et les autres
auditionné il serait assez peu
compréhensible que la présidence de
cette commission denquête n'y
souscrivent pas et si je dis ça c'est
que pardonnez moi nous avons eu un
épisode d'une commission d' enquête qui
n'est pas allée à son terme et qui n'a
pas souhaité procéder à un certain
nombre d'auditions qui était par
ailleurs réclamé
voilà donc là il parle de la commission
d' enquête qui concerne l affaire
benalla jean paul huchon est là la
république en marche avait clairement
désigné les personnes à auditionner
comment peut-on mener une commission
denquête si on choisit les personnes
effectivement il faut pouvoir
auditionner tout le monde
oui j'espère que c'est ce que l'on crée
un les assemblées je doute que ça
pichette cas de la l'espèce de
commissions bizarre qui serait piloté
par l'état ou un moment là pour l'elysée
tout ça n'est pas très satisfaisant mais
au fond du fond la réalité c'est que
nous avons riche et bien donner la
priorité à la santé sur l'économie
pendant un certain temps et cela a
conduit bien sûr un pour fournir la
crise économique mais c'était un choix
politique éthique et parfaitement
compensé mais maintenant il faut se
rendre compte que si on ne fait pas ce
qu'il faut pour le système de santé au
niveau des traitements au niveau du
matériel au niveau des investissements
alors on va on va vraiment être coupable
parce que c'est quelque chose c'était je
dirais le le nez les ultras de la france
de tenir un système de santé qui
marchait et aujourd'hui on commence à
voir les failles et il ya ce soir un
article dans le
monde a fait terrifiant qui dit en gros
que la france est passée dans la
deuxième division
par rapport à d'autres pays du monde sur
l'ensemble des grands investissements
santé transports éducation etc radon ni
faudra bien que les responsabilités
soient établies on peut pas avoir une
pandémie qui touche 3 milliards de
personnes et qui en france conduit à
30000 morts
malgré tout aujourd'hui malgré tous les
efforts des soignants on peut pas faire
comme si ça avait été un coup de chaud
et un malheur quelque chose d'exosun
bien sûr tout ce qui s'est passé
politique va devoir être assumée est ce
qui ce qui s'est passé également dans
les ehpad plus de 10000 nord aurait les
gros soit dans les ehpad qui doit en
répondre aux réunions
ça veut dire que si le gouvernement avec
les partenaires sociaux et les services
ne met pas en oeuvre un grand plan
veillissement il aura là aussi à
anticiper leur a perdu du temps et il
aura pris des riches
est ce que les gens peuvent changer les
gros il nous reste très peu de temps
reli gros est ce que le gouvernement
doit aussi répondre de six de ce qui
s'est passé dans les ehpad
je crois que il faut faut être clair
j'ai déjà parlé à des responsabilités en
tout cas de mon avis sur la question
mais pour répondre un petit peu
vous magali et à jean-paul je pense
qu'il faut prendre garde quand même
parce que l'action publique et politique
ne se retrouve pas uniquement placé sous
les fourches caudines de tel ou tel
tribunal le tribunal a enrayé le
tribunal médiatique le tribunal de
l'opinion publique le contrôle
parlementaire des inspections générales
le tribunal pénal les commissions d
enquête parlementaire
la propre investigation du gouvernement
dans sa propre gestion qui serait confié
effectivement à un professionnel
étranger médical à l'étranger
aussi on regarde aujourd'hui quand vous
regardez parce que tout à l'heure vous
poser la question sur la commission
parlementaire quand on regarde d'autres
affaires ou est auditionné si
effectivement le président le rapporteur
ne s'entendent pas et n'arrive pas à
travailler ensemble et que ça devient
que des procès politiques
cette commission denquête ne mènera à
rien or cette commission denquête elle
est faite pour quoi elle est faite quand
même pour trouver des des améliorations
pour engager une réflexion aussi sur ce
qui s'est passé
le pourquoi du comment et pour pouvoir
engager des améliorations dans la
gestion de notre pays en tout cas en
matière de santé donc je le dis pourquoi
je le dis parce que je pense que
aujourd'hui plus grand nombre ne voudra
s'engage en politique si les élus
deviennent les boucs émissaires de tous
les maux de la société c'est à mon sens
une erreur de fonctionner comme ça par
contre trouver les responsabilités sur
les épaules alors dire que le
gouvernement va être responsable de ce
qui s'est passé dans les ai pas je pense
que ce serait relativement exagéré par
contre qu'on dise que tout n'est pas mis
en place pour que les ehpad fonctionne
correctement qu'il ya un grand plan
santé à mettre en place maintenant il ay
travail et on sait très bien que le
dessin hospitaliers étaient dans les
rues bien là quelques semaines les
élèves
il ya eu des alertes effectivement il y
n'aura eu le talent herth il ne nous
reste plus attendre malheureusement je
tiens à dire je crois qu'aujourd'hui
cette crise ducobu va nous
permettre aussi peut-être d'alerté
réellement alors c'est dramatique d'en
arriver à à un extrême comme comme des
milliers de morts pour pour réfléchir
enfin à notre système de santé
mais clairement je crois qu'il faut tout
s'interroger collectivement sur notre
système de santé en france et pourquoi
pas lancer une grande concertation
citoyenne sur ce même système de santé
mais si un pc des professionnels de
santé au premier plan merci beaucoup et
migros et merci à vous jean paul huchon
d'avoir participé à ce débat c'est la
fin du débat politique week-end l'info à
suivre
[Musique]